Now recall, that we have actually
talked about five different steps
that are important in
creating a panorama.
First, of course,
is being able to capture images.
We've looked at how cameras work and
how we should be able to
use them to capture images.
We'll talk a little bit about it again
here specific to panorama building.
Then we have actually
discussed how to detect and
match features in images, a pair
of images or a sequence of images,
that will allow us to do alignment.
Then, of course,
we talk about how we can warp
an image to align the images to kind of
have no kinds of ghostly artifacts.
Then also, we actually looked
at how we can do blending,
both at the frequency level to
be able to kind of merge images,
we can fade images, and cut images.
The final part, cropping,
you know how to do, it's rather easy.
It's basically changing, of course,
the domain of the image itself,
that is finding the range at the,
at the number of columns and
number of pixels that we want to
actually use to do cropping.
Cropping, of course, is the last step
and it's an optional step to be able to
kind of now just create a rectangular
image out of a series of images that we
use to build a panorama and in essence,
it's really about finding the right
number of rows and columns and the
pixels to create a rectangular image.